[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose sister's getting divorced and it's
screwing up the friends and the family
and she doesn't know what to do next we
talked to a young man whose stepbrother
was one of the 13 men and women killed
in afghanistan and he wants to help his
family grieve
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john deloney show
so glad you're with us
so glad you're with us nick james kelly
it's good to see y'all especially kelly
[Music]
especially
hey uh
james i think it's time that we tell
everybody about our band
really you've mentioned it like every
show so i know you like how to do that
it's exciting for me
yesterday was our big coming out party
because we had nope i said that the
wrong way yesterday was the day that um
we had to get our big photo shoot
in our full gear
and we walked by kelly and kelly i
haven't seen stars in your heart and in
your eyes
ever like that i didn't know you were
capable of that level of
i know your heart fluttered in that way
oh it did but to be honest it was
strictly because
james is
there has been discussion about my taste
in music
you know james likes it if it's obscure
no one has ever heard of it
type thing
and i like my hair metal i don't
i don't shy away from that
so to see james dress like that he looks
so good to know
that here in a few weeks i'm going to
hear him play all the songs that are
near and dear to my heart does more for
me than y'all will ever know christmas i
didn't know you had a heart like that i
thought it was like like like a like a
small rock and yesterday was beating
fast oh it was it was a moment your hair
was standing out and cried a little i
saw it it was so good a tear
uh james this is a big moment it's grown
on me a little bit not all of it
but a lot of the taste to look across
our rehearsal space and see you holding
a gibson
rocking it
you're a 10x the guitar player i am and
to watch you play like that with the get
all of it my my heart's so full i feel
like i feel like hey we know this show
is failing miserably it's just on a swan
dive
but i feel like when this thing we all
have to just get in the room and be like
we tried this this show didn't work
i feel like i can look across the room
and think yeah but james rocked once and
uh
i've done my deed here we'll always have
summer of 2021. this
and maybe brian adams little brother
will write a song about it that'll be
fantastic
all right hey um hey listen check this
out
um i want to
talk about something cool uh a note that
i got here we get lots of uh negative
notes on the internets because people
love commenting we'll talk about that
someday
um but we got this great note
from
a wonderful woman named pat if you're
from here in tennessee
and here's what she said she said i
wanted to let you know that i tried one
of the suggestions that you make on your
show whenever i get an email it starts
with that i always think uh-oh
i don't think people are actually going
to do this stuff in real life
she said our adopted son 16 has several
different diagnosed mental health
challenges that a result from trauma
experience before he came to us at the
age of two
he had a really bad day yesterday and
his internal struggle manifested itself
as extreme anger towards me
the problem again when he shut down
emotionally refused to go to school and
he knows that if he refuses to go to
school then he's got some consequences
throughout the house
he wasn't speaking to me because i
upheld the consequences and he told me
that he would never forgive me
i love 16 year old um ultimatums and
absolutes
but as a parent it hurts
right it hurts
it's like my little daughter a couple
weeks ago
uh i wish you were never born or
whatever she said
so after he went to bed last night i
found a notebook
and i wrote him a note telling him how
much i love him and how important it is
for us to keep our word sticking to our
contract and that i hope that his friday
would be a better day
i also asked that he leave me a note to
let me know how he was doing
i left the note sitting on top of his
things in our study
this morning after he went to school
smiley face which he went to school
i checked the notebook there was one
sentence
i'm doing better today
and then she writes in all caps this is
amazing
i really didn't believe he'd write me
back but he did
he was introspective and he wrote back i
mean his exclamation points i left
another note and we'll wait to see if he
will continue a dialogue thanks to you
and your amazing team
uh probably talking about nick sarah
maybe james
and kelly thanks to you and your amazing
team for the work that you do have so
many major challenges going on in a
mama's heart these days and your advice
and expertise not only helpful
kelly is beautiful and entertaining she
didn't say that but i added that
um i look forward to every episode keep
up the good work hey pat number one
thank you for doing something as simple
as trying something new
trying something new
as parents we often tr like
we need to uphold these consequences
with a kid and when they don't do it we
think well we just need to hold
consequences even harder and then our
kids push back because they're 16 and
that's what the way 16 year olds are
biologically designed is to push back on
boundaries and then we think what do we
do let's just do it harder and louder
and you know we just and you tried
something different
you still held the boundary still held
uh
your son accountable
because you love him and he tried
something new
which was as simple as grabbing an old
spiral notebook or an old notebook off
some random shelf in your house
and writing him a letter and then just
saying hey he write me back and for a 16
year old who struggles with mental
health challenges who has sworn i'll
never forgive you and i'm not talking to
you
a sentence i'm doing better today
that's i mean that's like that can be
considered a parade right with horn
sections and things so confetti falling
from the sky
as parents as people who love
you know have romantic partners people
who are just trying to navigate our
world
so easy to get stuck in a rut
and we get an idea this is the way this
should be and when it doesn't work we
just think well let's just do it harder
and let's just do it louder and let's
just do it more aggressively
and sometimes deserve magic
just stopping and trying something new
so thank you so much for that email and
for some inside baseball this is the
second or third or like fourth time
we've had to pick this up and sarah the
editor is going to have to figure this
all out we'll be right back on the dr
john dolone's show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid where do i find a
counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey what's up ann
in richmond virginia and how in the
world are you
i'm good how are you good i know you can
hear us talking when we're not on air
and i'm you can tell i'm not i'm not
very good at this um
you also owe kelly a lot of money
because you've said listen so far twice
so oh come on kelly wasn't even paying
attention
real cool ann
you were
you were that kid in school they were
like can we just do more homework
and probably oh gosh darren's looking at
my paper thanks ann and the world needed
the world needs more ads
i should listen twice kelly's going to
get a cadillac after this deal
hey so what's up how can i help
uh so um anyway um
my sister and i have like always been
pretty close
um we got married around the same time
and then the
two of us couples were really close
and
now they're doing a divorce and
people are just trying to figure out
like how to navigate this and how they
manage to stay friends and keep things
sort of normal for all of our kids and
what do we do
so is everything i mean that messes up
weekends
evenings babysitting
hey we're going to yeah
and then you'll have like um
the same gang of friends too outside of
your little family bubble oh gosh okay
so why are they getting divorced is
there any any like abuse or
um
evil stuff going on or do they just fall
out of love and blah blah blah
[Applause]
i think it's mostly
the just
they grew apart or she grew up and he's
kind of the same person he's always been
and
i don't think
i don't see it as he's a bad person
as much as they just don't see eye to
eye and also and
he
he can be a little bit on the
controlling side when things aren't the
way he thinks they ought to be he just
wants people to like to try to buckle
down and
[Music]
come i don't know
try harder for his way rather than
compromise and so i don't see it as
abuse but definitely not healthy either
okay and i said something that i hate i
actually i said did they just fall out
of love i don't i don't really think
that happens i think people just quit
working on it so it sounds like they
over time just stopped working on stuff
right
and that's the way i see it okay all
right i mean i haven't been i haven't
been there you know
24 7 so right you know
that's right so i can't say 100
here's a couple of things
it really is going to come down to how
mature everybody wants to be
and
so the first thing i want you to be
cognizant of and put on the table in
your home with your husband
is this will send shockwaves through
your marriage
it will send shockwaves through you
through your husband and through y'all's
through your connection
right great and he'll it can be a
oh we can just get out of this thing or
i don't want that to happen to us or now
it's become real like oh this can happen
right it everybody kind of trips out a
little bit there's grieving that has to
happen on yalzan
and if y'all haven't gone out one night
or one morning and just said
this is gonna affect us
how are we then you gotta do that
because there's gonna be a lot of
unspoken stuff
um yeah how similar or am i right has
this happened
um to some extent and then i feel like i
feel like we're gonna you know like
we've realized that things are
it could happen but things are you know
we talk more and like i don't know it's
like we're in a good spot right now cool
you know
nothing nothing could happen but
there you go so i want you all to look
at this as a chance to
reimagine where you all are
headed and where you all are right now
and make this fun if you can get away
for a weekend on how how old your kids
are but if you don't get away for a
weekend if you can get away for an
afternoon or an evening do that and make
this so fun
so fun and it doesn't have to be a oh no
we don't want to become them i think you
got to put that on the table and say hey
this is
this is just sucks and this is scary and
this is and
um where do we want to go what is next
two years three years seven years gonna
look like for us we don't know what the
world's gonna look like but who are we
gonna be in the midst of all the mayhem
and um yeah i think that's so good so
when it comes to friends and
relationships and family and this kind
of stuff if there is abuse
like if he was beating up your sister
there's some
relationships like we're we're cutting
people off right
or if there's child abuse things like
you're not gonna be around my kids not
gonna be around my home et cetera
my again my friends we've been together
for so long but we're really open about
this stuff
and so
back when
one night we were all just hanging out a
couple of my oldest buddies somebody
just said it out loud like hey by the
way if any of us ever get divorced
i'll love y'all but your wife is welcome
to come stay at my house
like no questions asked right
so i think it would be really wise and
very mature and grown up of you
to if they can be in the same room if
you all can still sit in the same room
together then to invite them over for
dinner and say
we're still having all the kids together
you all too can do your thing but i'm
still going to call him i'm still going
to call you
and the two husbands are still going to
go hang out and go do whatever they do
and me and you are going to that's still
going to happen and we're not going to
pick sides here
and we're not going to get drawn into
any drama and oh why didn't you respond
to my text you respond i heard i hear
you're talking to him
i think just calling that out
putting it on the table y'all have
chosen to not be married we are choosing
to still love both of you does that make
sense
yeah and we've tried that and now we're
getting some pushback and like why do
you spend time with him and
there you go so here's what you did you
put a boundary on the table and your
boundary was we're gonna love you both
and now they're gonna people are gonna
bang their head up against that boundary
and see if it's real
and so this is when you respond back and
say hey i'm not doing this i love you
and if you're gonna tell me that to be a
sister who loves you it means i have to
cut off friends
um i'm not gonna do that or maybe you
say okay i'll do that and you tell him
hey i've gotta i love you but i gotta
side with my sister on this one
and you're gonna need to find your own
gang right if you all wanna do that then
so be it and when it comes to the other
friends i think you let them know we're
still going bowling or i don't know what
you guys what your friends do together
um
like
we're still gonna go do those things
we're gonna invite everybody
y'all to you can decide cause you all
made a grown up decision
you all too can decide
and here's the other thing that's gonna
just
just is a grenade in the middle of
everything
is everything's gonna be different now
it's gonna be weird there's gonna be
that awkward fleshing out part and the
uh it's just gonna be weird there's not
gonna be a when do we get back to normal
cause there's gonna have to be a new
normal and you all get to design what
this new normal is gonna look like but
it's gonna be annoying and frustrating
and it's okay to be so mad at your
sister for screwing everything up and
it's gonna be fine to be mad at this
dude um her ex for screwing everything
up and partridge in a pear tree but
holidays are gonna look different
thanksgiving christmas it's all gonna
look different right
yeah it's as intentional as possible and
then just don't put up with people
acting like children i i thought you
were gonna be my friend more and stop
we're not doing that right
okay
how much is that happening or are you
imagining it happening
um
recently it has been happening because
basically just
like just the way circumstances where we
were hanging out with her more and then
we got invited to do some stuff with him
and then and other friends fell together
and now she's upset about that and like
it's not about him it's like the whole
group of friends and
we want to do this and now she's like
not happy
yeah so in her grief
and in her shame and in her frustration
and in her anger
she's gonna have to find repeated
scapegoats
and as her best friend and sister and
also as the adult in the room
you are gonna be the brunt of this
unfortunately that's where you just
calling her out like dude i love you
stop this stop stop acting like a child
and this is gonna be heartbreaking for
you
but if she chooses to act like a child
and disconnect from you because you're
acting like a grown-up
that may be part of what's next for you
for a while i don't think it will be
forever but that may be what's coming up
does that make sense
that's heartbreaking i know but here's
the thing when we love people
people just do dumb things
they do stupid things they do things
differently than we do
and they do things that frustrate us
they do things that are incredible they
win the lottery and then suddenly he's
like oh what happened
that's just part of loving people it's a
risk and it's hard and that's when you
have to know who your gang is what your
values are what your boundaries are
and then how you're going to speak him
into the world
and i hope your sister will love you and
go i know i know
and that's when you guys are that's when
a sister who loves or can say do you
really think i don't love you stop
and we're going to go hang out with
friends and if you don't want to come
cause you divorce this guy that's your
choice congratulations but we're going
bowling because we love bowling and i'll
still come over your house but we're not
gonna keep a tally how many times with
him or with me and by the way he'll get
remarried someday
and um if he's like most guys it'll be
about two and a half weeks from now
he'll
run into some old middle school
girlfriend and just call it
and um he'll end up making his own life
so some of this is going to be temporary
and then you and your sister will stay
connected at some point so
um some of us just getting through the
discomfort of where we are right now
so frustrating but you and your husband
you all be the adults in the room hold
your boundaries and take care of those
little kids make sure they're all
hanging out together all right we'll be
right back on the dr john de loni show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we're back let's go to david
in raleigh north carolina one of the
most beautiful cities in the country
what's up david
john thank you so much to you and uh
mostly kelly i guess for having me on
the show come on
i'm sorry hey listen she called last
night and was like uh i've got like
seven calls and i said we're getting
david on this show just kidding that
didn't happen at all fake news
and that fake news is fake news how do
you like them apples
i'm just kidding david yes you can think
kelly she's the best and great and
wonderful and brilliant and
blah
blah
so anyway hey brother david what is up
man
well i just want to say um i've got so
much respect for you and what you do and
how you approach mental health so just
thank you for what you do i'm grateful
for you too john
oh i see what you did there
thanks man so hey i'm grateful for you
too so what's up man
yeah so
um i got a call from my mom two weeks
ago
saying that my brother who was deployed
in afghanistan was one of the 13 service
members killed in the kabul bombing come
on man i'm so sorry
wow yeah it's
it's
it's complex because my
my mom just remarried two years ago okay
and i've only met only met the guy once
okay so i don't really have
any kind of relationship with this guy
so i'm just kind of trying to navigate i
have a good you know good relationship
with my mom and my stepdad and i'm just
trying to figure out how i can
be there for my mom because this is we
just we just grieved my dad passing five
years ago so it's it's a lot of grieving
and you know i'm tired of
tired of her having to deal with crap
like this yeah man it's hard
everything about this is hard man um man
she's lucky to have you in her life for
thinking about her and for loving her
and um
dang man that sucks i'm heartbroken for
your family
so five years ago your old man passes
away was it sudden was it quick was it
slow
he yeah he had a heart disease it was a
very
very slow decline but it was it was a
quick quick death so you know he was
slowly you know his legs were
starting to swell
and he was kind of slowing down not able
to exercise as much but
it wasn't like okay he's gonna pass you
know we know he's gonna pass it was it
was very sudden
gotcha
so
then she gets remarried a few years
later is that right
yeah okay and then she i mean these
servicemen passed away were so stinking
young so she's probably spent a year or
two with them
yeah so they um
my stepdad they had a good relationship
with him
um he's been
stationed out here near i don't i don't
actually know it's somewhere out here in
north carolina sure but uh so they got
to see them quite a lot okay
so
how did your mom reach out to you
well she had she's been texting me
saying hey because he had just gotten
deployed uh my step brother just got
deployed like
several days before it happened so
it was
hey you know pray for ryan he's going to
afghanistan yeah and then
on
thursday it was hey
we haven't heard from him
um you know be praying that he's safe
and then i wake up to a call from her
and she's not she's not one to have a
quick conversation but it was it was
very quick it was
he was he was just killed uh pray for
pray for your stepdad yeah
man
man so have you been able to see your
mom in person
no uh she's there over in tennessee so
it's a bit of a drive okay
so
when anyone says like hey how do i help
somebody grieve
especially when someone's a family
member especially someone's involved in
this loss in any way
and um
the first thing i always tell folks is
make sure you're grieving
make sure you're dealing with your
frustration and your anger and your loss
and like you said you didn't know this
guy very well but there's some
peripheral connection there right and
you just yeah as a fellow united states
citizen like the rest of us are just
horrified at this thing
um and so
you you making sure you're okay and not
okay you're not just gonna flip a switch
but making sure that you have a process
you've got people in your life you're
taking care of your
basic health needs and things like that
and you've got folks that you can talk
to that's
super critical to make sure you can be
whole in the presence of somebody who's
hurting right
um
i think it's worth how old are you man
i'm 23. 23.
are you
are you in school what are you doing
right now
yeah i'm i'm i'm married and i've got a
i'm self-employed okay
if at all possible i think being in
proximity with your mom even if it's 24
or 48 hours is really valuable right now
um being able to let her touch you and
hug you and kiss your face
and hold her hand
um feels like a what would i actually i
mean what am i going to do i'm just
going to sit there and i would tell you
yes
absolutely you'll just sit there
and maybe you
take her by the hand and you'll go get
some breakfast or some go to dinner or
something together
you are able to hug your father-in-law
um your stepdad if you will not
father-in-law your stepdad you're able
to hug him and again he didn't know you
that well but he's connected in
different ways
and your role will take on a different
you know meaning to him but
being able to just be seen and be
touched and you hold your mom will
be a healing
it will be magical healing if you will
and so if you can knock off 48 hours i
know it's a long drive it's an
exhausting drive but if you can make
that drive or catch a flight and
go hug your mom
i would really recommend that i've done
turnaround trips like that for drive 12
hours or 9 hours for 10 hours of sitting
by somebody to then turn around and
drive another 9 or 10 or 11 hours back
those moments are magical and they are a
gift and they are few and far between
um as it as trying to love somebody and
help them grieve long distance
the the magic here is not i keep saying
magic because it's a mystical process in
many ways
the magic is to not try to fix your mom
you can't you can't take away her hurt
you can't take her away her disbelief
you can't take away
this is a big one right this one's got a
lot of baggage to it because there's
so many different voices weighing in and
every time she turns on the news there
it is and every time she doesn't turn on
the news there it is and facebook groups
and texting and
the military processionals all that
stuff is just this reminder and this
constant reminder and it's part of the
healing process
and so not trying to get caught up in a
trap of hey mom here's what you need to
do
but more of hey mom how are you how's
today
how was yesterday
and not always doing it through text but
setting up time when i'm going to call
mom i want to hear her voice and she
needs to hear your voice
does that make sense
yeah
um what has the last few weeks been like
for y'all are y'all are you talking to
her is she in a is she
weeping i mean
how is she doing
yeah so um i called her
um you know i gave them a day or two
for the you know it's because i didn't
want to talk to them when they're just
in complete shock so i called her and
like two or three days after
uh was obviously still in shock but
called her just to say
hey
you know how are you what's what's it
been like
and it was
you know i could tell that they had been
kind of crying a lot and they were they
said you know lots of ups and downs but
most mostly
just crap about
news stations trying to get a hold of
them trying to interview them
been approached by some major
film industries about already filming a
documentary and trying to interview them
so it's a lot of
dealing with a lot of crap like that so
here's something else um my house and a
lot of this credit to my wife she's
she's amazing but
my house has become a place that people
will escape to
they'll come from all over the country
and come spend a couple of days or a
week or two and get away
and it may be that you reaching out to
your mom and saying i want to invite you
to raleigh
you all get off the grid
turn your phones off and just come see
us you don't need to be able to heal
where people don't know where you live
they're not going to sit outside your
house i'm going to follow you to the
grocery store
and media and film i mean they can be
relentless
and maybe offering a safe place for her
to come visit you and you have do you
have a little one
no we don't okay you have a dog
no we've got just a spare bedroom all
right get a dog and tell your mom
grant i don't know be one of those
people that says things like grand dog
or whatever those people who
have animals and they try to
anthropomorphize them into humans um do
that do something tell you how you got a
squirrel in the backyard that needs her
grand squirrel or something but invite
her to come stay with you she probably
won't but um really open that up and
yeah i really think you need to go see
her face to face
um so this happened today and i'll keep
this as broad as possible because i i
want to keep my friends personal life
personal but uh we got a call this
morning that of friends um people that
like some of our closest friends on the
whole planet um they had called 9-1-1
one of them um was real sick and ended
up uh
going to the hospital this morning so
i'm waiting here after this show i'll
get some updates on the way things are
going
when i heard that
i immediately picked up the phone and
called
and so this idea of i don't wanna i know
they're grieving and i don't wanna get
in the middle of that
if you love them and you're connected
get in the middle
let people know that you're thinking
about them can i do anything how are you
because a lot of people like you
mentioned will call because they want
something
they want to know information they want
to know
um how
how the grieving people are going to
make me feel better because i'm scared
and i'm alone and i'm angry too
and there's something about just cutting
through that stuff and saying i'm your
son how are you right so i would
encourage you to not wait they'll tell
you they won't answer the phone the guy
called this morning whose wife is in the
hospital he didn't answer but he knows
that i love him and i left him a message
and said don't call me back just want
you know i'm thinking about you praying
about you i'm thinking um uh if you need
anything holler at me and just want to
check in on you
those kind of things they people won't
always remember what you said they'll
remember that they heard your voice
they'll remember that they saw your face
and so you lean in against your own
discomfort and you call your mom every
day make sure she's doing okay invite
her to see her see you you show up
um but there's gonna be a process about
touch and care and connection in these
moments
don't try to fix your mom she's gonna
have a hard grieving season your stepdad
especially is gonna have a hard grieving
season
just think of how can i be with
not how can i fix does that make sense
yeah and then over time as your mom
begins to make meaning of this deal as
she begins to say what am i gonna do am
i gonna create a group for
recently deployed young men and women
and i'm going to create a group for
their moms or i'm going to create a
group for grieving
parents or as she begins to make meaning
of this and say the rest of my life is
going to be a about x y and z because of
this
um then you can support her and love her
and go to the 10ks and go to the rallies
or
be you know a guest writer on her blog
whatever it's going to look like for her
but she's going to always know you were
there and you're walking alongside her
and again i want to remind you
you're peripheral peripherally is that
the right word you were connected to
this you know six degrees of kevin bacon
but you're still connected to it
you're still gonna have people who reach
out to you you're still gonna have your
own
when you're watching the news or you're
frustrated or you see politicians trying
to spin this this way or that way
make sure you're dealing with your own
stuff that you're keeping a journal
you're writing stuff down you're
disconnecting yourself from some of
these feelings and your anger and your
rage and your frustration or your
sadness make sure you're dealing with
you man
because you lost your old man too a few
years ago i know your your mom lost her
husband but you lost your dad
and now you're watching your mom hurt
again and that's hard too it's all about
grief
and you're gonna listen to all the
different knuckleheaded friends you have
making their cases and saying this and
that's make sure you and your wife are
dealing with your grief too
and over time you're gonna find meaning
also
and i'll say this your mom's lucky to
have you man
to all the sons and daughters out there
let's love our parents when they're
grieving when they're heartbroken when
they're hurting
to reach out let's let's i know it's
awkward because they usually come to us
for our whole lives they've been taking
care of us and there's these moments
that it turns
when it's our job to reach out to them
and say how are you doing
and
just be honest this is a season of loss
so much loss
whether it's
go to deaths whether it's military i
mean there's so much loss loss lost
hurricane stuff
we got to cut through the
man
it feels weird or it's hard i don't know
what to say forget that call somebody
and say hey i love you i don't know what
to say right now but i love you
send the email send the text write the
letters make the calls
we need each other during the season of
grief we don't need your anger and don't
need your
we need you
just to reach out and care for each
other
david you're awesome brother thank you
so much um
and we honor your step brother we honor
him and the other 12
with all of our hearts and our minds and
we honor them by the way
by loving each other by getting up and
saying i'm gonna make the most of today
i'm gonna make the most of tomorrow
i'm gonna be kind i'm gonna be direct
i'm gonna be honest i'm gonna love each
other that's how we're gonna honor
we'll take care of our commitments we're
gonna do what we say
thank you so much for you dave and your
family
whoo james
man i'm struggling with this
one like when i went down that list you
were out i mean when i go down that list
these kids are so young i call them kids
they weren't kids i know they're not
kids i know they're adults
there's just 20 20 years old 20 years
old 20 years old someone those
young men and women couldn't buy drinks
it's unbelievable man
but
in honor of
good friends
i don't think i've told you that i may
have told this on the show
i've been trying my best james to raise
my son
as a guy
who understands
heavy metal roots
and good punk rock music and good hair
metal music and i know many will say is
hair metal good not it kind of it is
sort of
but i'm trying to raise him in the right
way
and then we moved to nashville and he
found this station 95 5
90s country hits
all day
every day out of his room
is martina mcbride and alan jackson
and
toby keith of everybody
and now these guys are our neighbors we
live here in nashville they're just
around in the grocery store and i look
at them and i think i tried to teach my
kid about metallica but you
you wrote some song about boot scooting
boogie and now my son's walking through
the world
i think my biggest takeaway is that your
son listens to
the radio the actual radio oh that is
amazing he recites geico commercials
he'll come out and be like guys there's
a sale at wendy's we can get four uh
most 11 year olds don't know what the
radio even is like i have to explain to
my kids can you put on that song i'm
like no no you can't pick the song on
the radio it's just whatever's on and
he's so fascinated by when he goes to
someone's house and they have like alexa
and he's like you can just tell a magic
box and it plays any song anyway
in honor of my son who i love in honor
of friends
it's off the 1990 album
no fences
no fences
our good friend g
our good friend g old g brooks
the lead single from the album no fences
it's friends in low places by our
brother garth and it goes like this
blame it all on my roots i showed up in
boots and ruined your black tie affair
the last one to know the last one to
show i was the last one you thought
you'd see there and i saw the surprise
and the fear in his eyes that's so great
when i took his glass of champagne and i
toasted you and said honey we may be
through but you'll never hear me
complain cause i got friends in low
places where the whiskey drowns and the
beer chases my blues away
and i'll be okay and i'm not big on
social graces i think i'll skip on down
to the oasis
oh i've got friends
in low places garth brook is such an
incredible song right here on the dr
john dolone's show